or on part maintenant au coeur du parc
de la brenne dans la réserve zoologique
de la haute touche c'est le plus vaste
parc zoologique français ils viennent de
rouvrir ses portes au public
il a que les visiteurs mais aussi des
scientifiques avec des protocoles de
recherche très pointu c'est une
découverte signé catherine lacroix et
mélissa genevois les pandas roux profite
du soleil printanier indifférent aux
nouveaux locataires de leur enclos les
grues de mandchourie
un jeune couple qui semble très bien
s'acclimater
ces groupes joris est parmi les plus
grands oiseaux en fait au monde c'est
une envergure qui avoisine les 3 mètres
d'envergure
hélas mais ça c'est pas une
particularité de cette seule espèce
encore une espèce menacée
encore une espèce un programme européen
d'élevage donc que nous gérons en
collaboration internationale au niveau
de l'association européenne des parcs
zoologiques le temps de se réhabituer à
la présence du public
les animaux flâne dans leur enclos
morgane brachet et spécialiste des
suricates
elle est arrivée en début de semaine
pour étudier la population de la réserve
privée l'habituation ce qu'au début on
reste près du sol parce qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus petits que nous donc si on
est debout ils sont tout de suite très
impressionné et du coup j'avais toujours
un petit pinceau qui marche qui marche
pas ça dépend
pour les habitués à venir le renifler et
le but du jeu c'est que je puisse
peindre une petite tache noire sur une
partie de leur corps qui va être
différente sur chaque suricates pour que
moi je puisse les identifier
individuellement et à partir de là
travailler avec eux pendant trois mois
elle va vivre au quotidien avec les sept
suricates du parc qui présente des
caractéristiques assez proche des
sauvages d'afrique du sud je travaille
sur le site l'ovule à thouars chez la
femelle suricates
on travaille en collaboration avec une
réserve en afrique du sud avec laquelle
moi j'ai déjà travaillé et du coup
l'idée c'est de manière non invasive
donc sans faire mal sur et 400 faire de
prises de sang sans faire de capture
d'étudier l'ovulation
les visiteurs pourront aussi voir les
travaux de l'îlot babouins puisqu'une
nouvelle colonie devrait s'installer
dans les prochains mois avec un
chercheur attitré qui fera intervenir le
public dans l'étude comportementale du
groupe
enfin dernière nouveauté le parc
proposera cette année un pass pour la
saison